between endless years of hopeless
existence and even a single moment of
hope I must choose hope I must find that
signal
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot's Metro
Exodus review my name is Jake and I'm
here with Michael if you haven't noticed
we're doing things a little bit
differently I brought him in here and
we're going to discuss his review now
you gave Metro Exodus an 8 but before we
get into why can you set up the game
tell me what Metro Exodus is about sure
it's a third game in the metro series
which is kind of like a safari survival
horror type of first-person shooter this
one does things a little different with
open spaces and it also got me in a way
I did not expect with its story and
characters and we'll get into that later
in the discussion but a reminder is that
an 8 out of 10 means great and I think
this is a great game and you mentioned
the open approach in your review and how
it doesn't quite nail some things I'd
say that is one thing you'd say that
doesn't nail correct yes so just to give
you some context is that Metro Exodus
has several chapters three big ones of
which are open sandbox hours long - yes
where is the the first two are kind of
traditional open worlds you can think
from as where there is you're free to
roam there's some side quests and
there's a main mission to go down the
thing there is that one part is that I
feel like the slow deliberate movement
of Metro was transported to a open space
that it wasn't really meant for so
getting around in those worlds is a
little difficult and kind of takes away
from the experience a little bit like in
Volga where it's in the wintertime
trying to get around the water parts the
row boats are slow the sea life that
attacks you it's annoying and kind of
makes the pace a little bit more abrupt
[Music]
caspian desert is like pretty barren
isn't much much to do and there's not
too many incentives to venture off into
these open areas aside from the side
quests that do get marked on your map so
that kind of leads me into the next
thing
Rodrigo on Twitter asked I know exit is
some more open space but how well does
it conserve that metro feeling and still
innovate for itself so I guess I think
what he means is that sort of
claustrophobic atmospheric dark feel
that you get from Metro I think if
that's one of your concerns going into
exodus you shouldn't be worried for a
does still does a great job of
instilling that fear that sense of
vulnerability that's really shines
through an exodus because that was one
of my favorite parts of both 2033 and
last light just how how scary it was to
be in those spaces but how easily you
can just like be killed by something
that you just not ready to handle those
moments pop up in Exodus you have a day
and night cycle in the open spaces but
you still have missions that funneling
you through these like it's terrifying
areas with enemies that are intimidating
so you're gonna get a lot of that out of
Exodus in addition to some of the more
open stuff that they do and unlike
previous Metro games because you've left
the metro and because you're exploring
Russia itself you don't really come
across vendors and it relies more on
crafting as opposed to currency with the
bullets which was a pretty clever system
in the old ones how you use bullets in
order to purchase different equipment
but this relies more on crafting how do
you think that worked so I will say that
I loved the military-grade bullet
currency in the previous games and said
now you're doing crafting where you have
two separate materials and you have to
make your own ammo or scavenge it and
then make your med kits or find those
and filters and all that the crafting if
you're apprehensive about Metro having
crafting again you shouldn't be worried
because it's a really good system
actually it's it's streamlined and it's
also complementary to the sort of the
tension that you feel in the game
because you have to make decisions as to
what you're gonna clean what you're
gonna upgrade yeah what ammo you're
gonna make yes there's this there's like
a sense of preparation because you can
only make ammo at workbenches
and before you venture off into accept
except for your crossbow bolts and your
and your steel balls that you can fire
out of your I forget with the pump gun
t-carr yeah yeah that's oh yeah animal
for your primary weapons can only be
made at workbench so there's a sense of
preparation there if you're not like
constantly scavenging the proper bullets
for whatever guns you have but you can
at least get like you said steel balls
and the arrows for your crossbow so at
least you have something to fall back on
in case you do run out of ammo but what
the system does is that you know it puts
you in control of what you want to
create but it also never forces you to
like you always have like a sense of
that you can you can make a situation
work even when you're like almost dead
or if you feel like you're between a
rock and a hard place you have a means
of getting out of it another thing too
is the the weapon attachment system or
the modifications you can also do that
through your backpack you pick them up
from enemy weapons but over time you
just kind of build up this arsenal of
attachments that you can put on your
weapons and that's another system that
plays into the crafting that I like
because you can pull out your backpack
and swap out attachments and it lets you
adapt to situations that may arise so I
talked a lot about in this example in
you know in the taiga missions which are
great you you kind of only have a
crossbow and I took down a few enemies
and picked up their guns because I
didn't have any at that point in the
story and what I did is I took like a
dinky revolver that wouldn't be great
for like firefights and then as soon as
I got it I swapped out a bunch of
attachments and then I had a very good
long-range weapon and I was able to you
know hold my own when I was clearing out
a bandit camp and at that moment I
realized like oh this is this the system
is really well done and it adds a layer
of depth to the already good firefights
and weapon feel that Metro last light
Elise already had so in that regard like
Exodus has incredible gunplay that's
really fun to engage with
[Applause]
so I think the next big thing to touch
on after reading your review is that you
really like the characters and how they
develop those characters and the arcs
they had over time can you talk a little
bit more on that yes the the character
progression and the world building for
metro Exodus is my favorite part
particularly how how earnest and genuine
everyone feels on this journey because
you're still playing as Artyom but of
course in this trek you bring some
friends along the way and in between the
the gameplay chapters I would say is
that you hang out on the Aurora which is
your train and it acts as like an HQ
like a new home away from home and here
you just kind of you hang out and listen
to people talk these aren't like
dialogue trees or you don't hit a button
to engage in a conversation these are
just ambient conversations that happen
on there and I found myself just sitting
there and listening to them talk to me
about their lives their stories their
aspirations or even just eavesdropping
on other characters yeah you get a lot
out of it because it's so well done like
the voice acting can be spotty and in
parts but the like just the stories they
tell and the way it's delivered the way
it's acted and how it kind of feeds into
the camaraderie that you end up feeling
towards like the end of this game it's
it's something new for the metro series
because they've they've had like
philosophical type of stories with like
the Dark One's and all that but here
it's it does away with that and more
focus is on the relationships I say this
in my review is that like these are
characters that you want to follow to
the ends of the earth which is kind of
essentially what you're doing in this
game
and that's because like they're so
endearing they're so earnest and for
example Stepan who's a big burly dude
who can play guitar house IT yeah he's
like a heart of gold and Tamir who's
trying to feel like make sense of his
ethnicity and culture and then finds it
eventually it's such an empowering like
smaller story and the bigger picture but
it's there and it happens and then when
I saw it was like this is it's does a
lot for the game and then Anna who's
your wife who just opens up to you in
such such genuine ways aboard the Train
and then Miller who's the leader who's a
hard-ass but still has like he hasn't
like that tough love love five this
silly dream of yours but don't you see
what you're doing to my daughter and
it's just these this band of characters
that you want to fight for III mentioned
I realized this after I finished the
game is that Wow there wasn't really any
central villain there wasn't like this
big bad person to take down instead
you're just fighting to survive and with
that in mind it's kind of like the thing
that drives you is how much you care
about this cast and you know Metro
Exodus does an incredible job of you
know making you care about this so what
by the time it wraps up you're like dude
that's my squad like I'll fight for
these people to the ends of the earth
and it's it's it's new for the series I
think and it's just I can't I can't stop
thinking about how how much that
affected me and how much that how much
that did for the overall experience once
I finished it like I'm gonna remember
this squad and the journey we went on
for first long as I can so that actually
brings up another point Alec abusal on
Twitter also asked as someone who has
not played the other Metro games would
it make sense to jump into Exodus even
with all of this character development
would you feel lost at all if you
started with Exodus
if you want to jump into Exodus by all
means do it even if you haven't played
the previous games because by virtue of
them doing something completely new with
the setting and its characters some
carryover from last light but they do
such new things with them that it kind
of doesn't matter they can stand on
their own in Exodus alone so it's you
shouldn't worry about whether
play 23:3 and last light but I'd say if
you can play those games because they're
still very good yeah and they're both on
current gen consoles PC as well yeah and
then another question is not super
exciting but something that people are
definitely curious about is how did the
game run and did you run into a lot of
technical issues I myself ran into a
couple pretty bad bugs but it didn't
hinder me too much like I still able to
finish the game yeah those things will
pop up and they're kind of frustrating
to be honest this is again this is
pretty day one patch so this may change
with the final release but I fell
through geometry right after a quick
save or after a checkpoint so that half
the captain is pretty funny I kept
loading and as I kept falling through
the geometry but I had a quick save from
like five minutes ago lost some progress
but whatever it's it's fine I'll live
and then I lost also equipment I went to
the workbench and all the sudden like a
lot of things weren't there which is
that was kind of frustrating too because
I had decked myself out in a way I
wanted to and then I couldn't anymore
hopefully that gets fixed but that was
also frustrating but framedrops - they
happen depending on your system some
people of course this always happens
some people say they have perfectly fine
performance
there's cool but I ran into some
framedrops I know you also ran to a lot
of frame jobs and you have a pretty
high-end PC as well so if you do
experience that don't be surprised so
that kind of leads into the next
question is well which is also a
question from Twitter from Steven
Davidson and he asked were there any
noticeable differences between the ps4
and PC versions I know you played both
you played PC and you played a little
bit on the ps4 we actually didn't get
Xbox codes so we don't know how it runs
on there but having played PC which is
obviously going to be the highest end
and in ps4 which is probably on the
lower and how did that run for you it's
it's pretty distinct I mean with with a
decent PC I can run native resolution
1080p or 1440p and get sixty Freight 60
frames per second which I which matters
a lot to me and then so with that in
mind I think there's a like a big
distinction between the PC versions and
the console versions but if you can only
play this game on like consoles they
the ps4 version at least in my
experience ran three stable albeit at a
lower frame rate of like 30 sub maybe
sometimes the sub 30 frames per second
but I mean it was playable and it's it's
not too surprising considering what like
console versions of PC games are you
know it's it's kind of comes with the
territory but if you if you can play on
PC that's definitely where you want to
be but if not don't worry console
versions are perfectly fine at least in
my experience
I mean stepping away from the review
itself and more into the broader
conversation an interesting thing about
this game is that they pulled it from
the steam store a couple weeks before it
was supposed to launch and I know this
has caused a lot of backlash from fans
yeah I guess what are your thoughts on
that in general it's you know if Elvis
salty about it I understand because it
was pulled about two or three weeks
before launch at least people who
pre-order Akande are still playing it on
Steam it is gonna come out in 2020 on
Steam but it's it's on the epic Store
it's not being taken away from PC as a
whole so it's it's not that big of a
deal to me I don't see a problem with it
and also it's $50 on the epics store as
opposed to the standard 60 I know I
don't know if this is the case but I
imagine that you know the fact that
developers and publishers get a higher
cut of their sales can't kind of
incentivize to them to sell it at $50 so
that's that's kind of a win for you know
people who play a game yeah but most
people who play in develop games yeah so
I don't I don't know what the problem is
I think people are just trying to stir
the pot or whatever but again I do
understand that valve is you know a
little salty about it before we close
out you have any last words closing
remarks that you would like to talk
about yeah yeah I think that I want to
mention the morality system at least
real quick because that returns from the
previous games and you know I think that
I got a good ending I'm not gonna talk
go into what happened but I think I got
a good ending and if looking back on my
review I feel like the the tone and like
the hopefulness and optimism that comes
out of that kind of fed into my my final
perception
the game and I know you and Michael
Hardy got there any different endings
from me
and it's a it's just wild to think about
how much you know the morality system
and how much I paid attention to it and
how that fed into the events that
unfolded kind of affected my overall
impression of the game and its story and
characters and also one more thing the
taiga chapter I know that's the third
kind of open science sandbox great level
one of the best levels in all of Metro
it's probably the highest point
gameplay-wise before this game yeah
because it definitely blends in those
open areas with the with the for linear
sections as well as very well yeah that
level is a masterpiece
anyway that is Michael's and game spots
review of Metro Exodus let us know what
you think of this new review style we're
kind of trying things out and make sure
to stay tuned to games Bob because there
are a [ __ ] ton of reviews coming down
the line that's only Metro nothing else
and the order is here to defend it
because if not us then who
[Music]